الى موضوع طبي جدلي والذي اثير مجددا بعد
وفاه وديع نجل الفنان جورج وسوف بعد
اجرائه عمليه جراحه تكميم للمعدات حيث
عاده تتساؤلات عن مخاطرها وتداعيتها
الجانبيه على صحه الانسان عاده ما يلجا
لهذه العمليه الاشخاص ممن حاولوا ينقص
وزنهم بالطرق التقليديه مرارا لكن لم
يوفقوا في ذلك لكنها تظل في النهايه عمليه
جراحيه قد يكون لها اعراض جانبيه ومخاطر
تصل حد الوفاه فهل يستدعي حلم الرشاقه
الذي يراود كثيرين ان يقوموا بمثل هذه
العمليات خاصه ان من تعرضوا لخطر او توفوا
من مشاهير بسببها اجر هذه العمليات على
ايدي كبار الاطباء نتعارف اولا مع لميس
على عمليه تكميم المعده ونفتح ملفنا
بالتفصيل
تعد جراحه تكميم المعده واحده من العمليات
الجراحيه الدقيقه التي تهدف الى فقدان
الوزن الذين يعانون من السنه المفرطه
تعتمد على قصد نسبه كبيره من المعده تصلح
حوالي 80% من حجمها الكلي لها اعتقنيات
مختلفه اذ يمكن استخدام التدبيس او اضافه
حلقه سيليكون حول مدخل الطعام لضمان عدم
عوده تمدد المعده مره اخرى عمليه شائعه
جدا تشير ارقام الا انها 380,000 شخص
سنويا يجرونها حول العالم
ولك اي عمليه لها مخاطر ومضاعفات النزيف
او العدوى واحيانا ردود فعل على التخدير
اما بعد العمليه قد يحدث تراكم الطعام في
المريء ما يصعب الحصول على العناصر
الغذائيه الكافيه نتيجه لاكل كميات اقل
بكثير كما ان فقدان الوزن السريع يمكن ان
يجعل المراره معرضه
فقره معوضات ينضم الينا من القاهره دكتور
احمد ابراهيم شاهين استشاري الجراحه
العامه والمنظير المتقدمه وجراحات السنه
المفرطه ومن بيروت اخصائيه التغذيه ريتا
مكاري اهلا بكم يا دكتور اهلا بك يا ريتا
نحاول في دقيقه ان نفهم مع وضد سبب كل
منكم بهذا الموضوع
لماذا تؤيد اجراء عمليه تكميم المعده رغما
حاله الوفاه الكثيره التي سمعناها من
اشخاص اجروا هذه العمليه
صباح الخير عليكم همم اولا احنا بنقد
المحر التعازي للفنان جورج وسوف في وفاه
نجله
احنا خلينا نتكلم الموضوع مش مش بصفه ان
انا مع او ضد خلينا نتكلم الموضوع
انجينرال او على العموم انه
ما فيش تعارض ما بين العمليات الجراحيه
والتغذيه العلاجيه او او انه العيان يعمل
رجيم او خلافه بالعكس احنا بنبدا مع
العيان اولا انه حضرتك دلوقت همم احنا
قررنا اجراء عمليه جراحيه بس دي لها شروط
الشروط المعاينه دي بتبدا اولا بعد فشل
همم الاجراء الاحترازي اللي هو ال- همم
التغذيه العلاجيه او برامج ريجيم معينه
ساعتها بنختار ان احنا خلاص لازم العيان
يتخلص من هذه المشكله عن طريق اجراء عمليه
فطبعا لا يوجد تعارض ما بين التغذيه
العلاجيه او او البرامج العلاجيه والعمليه
احنا بنرجع للعمليه بعد فشل جميع الطرق
الاحترازيه زي
التنظيم الغذائي او البرامج الغذائيه
المعينه
التغذيه ريتا لماذا انت معارضه لعمليات
تكميم المعده رغم بعد الفوائد الطبيه التي
يتم الحديث عنها
من خلال الاكل ومن خلال الرياضه ومن خلال
تغيير نمط الحياه تبع الشخص بيقدر هو ينزل
وزنه هذا الشيء على المدى الطويل لان
اليوم العمليه بتوصل لك بعد سنه سنتين انك
تخسري وزن محدد بس بعدين على الشخص انه
يرجع يحسن بنمط حياته الاكل اول شيء هو
دواء بس كثير ناس ما بتامن انه في اشياء
مسموحه لها وفي اشياء ممنوع على الاله
فلهذا السبب بيضل له بصراع انه انا اي
دايت بدي اعمل اي دايت الاحسن لك بالفعل
انه اليوم احنا بنوقف ناكل فئه معاينه من
الاكل لانه ما بتناسب جسمنا احنا راح نشوف
انه الوزن تبعنا عم بينزل بلس قصه النمط
الحياه كثير ناس بتحط اولويه شغله همم
الحياه الاجتماعيه تبع همم التعصيب ستريس
وبتهمه صحتها ما بتحطها بالمركز الاول
وهذا الشيء بيخلي هرمونات
ان احنا نخزن دهون حتى لو ما اكلنا فمنها
المنطلق في كثير ناس اذا راحوا عند
بسيكولوج اذا راحوا عند يمكن مرشد روحي
ساعدوه لانه هو هن يخففوا هيدا ستراس او
ينظم حياتهم بطريقه انه يعطوا وقت لصحتهم
تيقدروا يعملوا رياضه تيقدروا ياكلوا صح
بعتقد انه هذا الشيء على المدى الطويل
كفتره حياه بيقدروا يوصل له نتيجه كثير
احسن من قصه تصغير المعده اللي هي بتوصلك
لمرحله معينه وانا بالعيد كثير بيعملوا
همم عمليات وبيرجع بشوفهم بعد سنه بعد
سنتين بيقولوا ياريت عم بيرجع انصح اريد
توقف وزني ما بقى عم بضعف طيب شو لازم
اعمل يكونوا هن الاشياء البدائيه طبعا
النظام الاكل فيه يعني انه ما ياكلوا حلو
يخففه من كميه النشويات لانه كل الجسم
عنده كميه معاينه من الاكل قادر يحرقها بس
اذا انت ما تعلمت اليوم كيف لازم تاكله
الكميه اللي بيحقق لك اياها بالنهار
مواعيد الاكل اللي انت بتناسب جسمك مش
ممكن حتى لو عملت العمليه تضلك عم تقدري
تضعفي دكتور احمد بالنسبه لعمليات تكميم
المعدات ما هي مخاطرها اولا ولماذا تقول
الى الوفاه في بعض الحالات
مبدئيا بس خليني اركب على كلام الدكتور هو
طبعا زي ما قلت لحضرتك احنا ما فيش اي
تعرض يا دكتور ما بين العمليه والبرامج
الغذائيه بالعكس احنا بعد العمليات بنعتمد
على البرامج الغذائيه بدرجه كبيره جدا مع
استشهاده التغذيه احنا مخاطر عمليه
التكوين المعده هي عمليه تكميم المعده
عمليه بسيطه بس طبعا هي احنا بنقول ان هي
بسيطه نتيجه
التطور الكبير في الادوات وفي ادوات الكي
وفي الدباسات والكلام ده كله همم احنا
العيال اللي بنشتغل فيه العمليات دي هو زي
ما قلت في حياتك انه لازم يكون مبدئيا
حاول مره واثنين وثلاثه مع الانظمه
الغذائيه هو فشل فبنضطر نرجع الى الجراح
الاجراء الجراح اليومين دول امن بالنسبه
كبيره جدا فوق ال 90% او 95%من طبعا بس
نتيجه انه العيان ده كتله الجسم بتاعته
عاليه فبيبقى معرض للمخاطر اكثر من غيره
يعني مثلا العيان اللي هو وزنه 150 او 200
كيلو لو انا باعمل له عمليه مراره او
عمليه زي ده بعيد عن عمليه السمنه خالص هو
معرض لمخاطر برده مخاطر ال- اا او مختلفه
كثيره او هذا الطباعه خاطئ طبيه
لا هو خلينا نقول انه دي اعراض جانبيه
متعارف عليها للعمليه وليست اخطاء طبيه
بالدرجه الاولى لانه المريض ده غالبا
معظمهم بيبقى يعاني من امراض السكر امراض
الضغط امراض الشريطيه فطبعا هو بيبقى معرض
لان العمليه نفسها ما هياش همم قاتله
للعيان لا مش قاتله للعيال العمليه بتبقى
امنه بنسبه كبيره جدا بس دي اعراض جانبيه
متعرف عليها علمين وليها نسب قانونيه
ومتفق عليها برده عالميا مش هنظلم احد
ونقول انه ده خطا طبي او كذا يعني احنا
بنقول ان في مخاطر العمليه وهو حديث
الساعه حديقه
جورج وسوف
ما الذي حصل باعتقاتكم
هو طبعا انا مش هاقدر احكم على اللي حصل
تحديدا بالضبط لان لم اطلع على حاله
المريض قبل العمليه او الفايل الطبي او ما
حدث انما حدوث نزيف ما بعد عمليات جراحه
السمنه له نسب قانونيه مثلا اقل من النصف%
ااا حدوث تسريب في المعده نسبوه مثلا
بنتكلم في 2% وده والده الحدوث انما ما
حصل الاستاذ وديع طبعا انا مش هاقدر احكم
عليه او لانه لم اتابع الحاله شخصيه يعني
طيب
بالنسبه للناس الذين لا يملكون العزيمه او
حاول كثيرا ولم ينجحوا في انقاص وزنهم
ماذا تنصحيهم يا ريتا
انا اول شيء بنصحهن انه اكيد يكونوا
متاكدين انه جربوا الدايت يلي بتناسب جسمه
لانه اليوم نحنا بنعرف انه اذا كانت
الانسولين عالي في جسم الانسان يعني عنده
نوعيه اكل ما فيه كلا وهو لازم يكون مقتنع
انه على مدى طويله يعني يوم اغلبيه
العالميه اللي بتعمل دايت وبتقول انه ما
زبط هم بيعملوا على فتره كثير قصير
وبيحبوا على حاله بيفكروا انه جسمهم بيقدر
يتصلح بطريقه كثير سريعه بينما نحن بحاجه
الى ست شهور نحنا تنزبط هرموناتنا من خلال
الاكل اليوم انت اذا بتقعد سته اشهر بلا
ما تاكل نشاويات بلا ما تاكل سكر بلا ما
تاكل كميه هائله من الكحول مثلا همم الوقت
راح تتضبط
انت
مرتبطه كمان بالنمط الحياه اذا اذا الشخص
عائش نمط كثير في ضغط كثير في تعب حاطط
الشغل اولاويه الاجتماعيه
فهو يقدر يركز فانا هون بعتبر الاراده هي
ما لنا مرتبطه انه ولا انا عندي اراده او
ما عندي اراده لا انا او عم بساعد حالي
انه انا اطلع من هالنمط الحياه يعني انا
عايش عيش عيشته تاع كرمال اقدر التزم
بحميه غذائيه معينه يعني مثلا في ناس
بيقولوا بما انه ما عنده وقت تحضر اكل او
اخذ همم خيار صحي انا بطلب من دايت سنتر
اكل كامل جهزت ما يعيد عندي الحجه انه انا
اكل هذه على السرعه او او على ضغط الوقت
او مثلا في ناس ما بتعيد تشتري عبايتها
اشياء بتخليها هي تنصح لان ما بتناسب همم
صحتها
الاراده ما في حدا ما عنده اراده وكثير
ناس بتعتبر انه انا ولا فشلت لانه انا عند
الاراده وهو بالوقت انه جسمه مريض جسمه مش
قادر انه يلتزم
بهبط السكري يا نوعيه الاكل يعني
حنين وياما اوقات بدايه كتير بسيطه مثلا
تنقول اذا بياكلوا الصبح ترتين ابعد خبز
مثلا ما جبنه ببلشوا نهارهم بطريقه غلط
وهذا شيء بخليهم كل النهار قابليتهم فاتحه
على الاكل
الدكتور احمد
هو النظام الغذائي الصحي والرياضه طيب
دكتور بالنسبه للناس لتكميم المعده
للضروره الطبيه وليس للرفاهيه ما هي
النصائح خطوه بخطوه لتجنب المخاطر ان لا
يمكن التنبؤ بذلك الطبيه
لا طبعا هو خلينا نقول انه ال اللجوء
للعمليه طبعا بيبقى حل اخير احنا احنا مش
هنختلف في انهو الحال اللي طبعا حل اخير
طبعا احنا لازم طبعا العين يبقى فاهم كويس
جدا انها بتعمل عمليه مش صغيره طبعا بنشرح
له كميه نسبه الامان اللي موجوده في
العمليه كويس جدا والادوات المستخدمه
ونسبه الحدوث مضاعفات مضاعف عليها عالميا
بنسب معينه زي ما بنتكلم مثلا زي ما قلنا
ال- ال- النزيف مثلا بيبقى اقل ونصف في
المئه حدوث مثلا همم تصريف في المعده
بيبقى بنتكلم في اثنين ونصف في المئه هي
الفكره في حدوث المضاعفات الطبيه وليس خطا
طبي هو سرعه التشخيص وسرعه العلاج يعني
مثلا ان احنا بنتكلم في نزيف همم بيحصل
بعد العمليه ما هو ممكن يحصل بعد اي عمليه
ثانيه مش شرط تكميم المعده بس ممكن يحصل
انه همم تسريب من الجهاز الهضمي كله في اي
عمليه خاصه بالجهاز الهضم مش شرط التجميل
اا الفكره في سرعه التشخيص وسرعه العلاج
هو ده المفتاح الاساسي في تجنب احداث حدوث
حالات وفاه كثيرا يعني انما طبعا لو لو
قارنا او عملنا احصائيات بالنسبه لعدد
للعمليات اللي بيتعمل والمشاكل الصحيه
اللي اللي بتحصل هنلاقي طبعا المشاكل
الطبيه اللي بتحصل مش بالكم الكبير اللي
احنا بنسمع عنه طبعا يعني انما ال- ال-
الفكره زي ما بنقول احنا بنشرح للعيان همم
العمليه بتفاصيلها كامله بكل الادوات
المستخدمه انه ممكن يحصل كذا ونسب وكذا
ممكن يحصل نزيف وممكن يحصل تسريب هي
الفكره وال- طبعا والمتابعه اللاصقه
للعيان في اول من 10 ل 15 يوم انه العيان
همم بنطمن عليه بصفه دوريه او بصفه يوميه
في اول 15 يوم اللي هو طبعا همم بيحدث في
معظم الاعراض الجانبيه او اللي ممكن تحصل
اا طبعا هي ال ال الفكره كلها ان احنا
بنقول الفرق ما بين الاخطاء الطبيه ده
حاجه والفرق الثاني ما بين
الاعراض الجانبيه المتعارف عليها علميا ده
موضوع ثاني الفرق بينهم كبير جدا
اهدي نصايح القايمه دكتور احمد ابراهيم
استشاري الجراحه العامه والمناظير متقدمه
والجراحات السمنه المفرطه وكانت معنا كذلك
من بيروت اخصائيه التغذيه للتامري شكرا
جزيلا لكم